[Musique]
oui
en haut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
m
une suite
[Musique]
alors viendra madame merci merci pour
tout et puis on espère qu'il y aura une
12e 13e 14e 20e 30e saison on t'aime pas
d'anniversaire bisous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
canal est là pour me fais tous les jours
des gâteaux place du soir au poste merci
monsieur comment ça va mais à fond
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez tué ouais isabelle
morini bosc à l'heure dans l'eau je
voulais qu'elle refasse des trucs hollow
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais remercier toutes les équipes
du splash asnières ainsi que l'ensemble
du groupe les bistrots parisiens voilà
qui nous ont aidés à monter
l'anniversaire bravo à eux on embrasse
tous les restaurateurs tous les tous les
champions des bars en bars parlais tout
à l'heure mais c'est vrai qu'avec ce qui
arrive on pense fort à lui